let's bring in Republican congressman
from the great state of Wisconsin Sean
Duffy Sean you know we knew you were
going to be on so a big breaking news
night we got Andrew McCabe deputy
director of the FBI
fired right before his big pension is
going to kick in huge controversy
swirling around this some already crying
foul saying this firing is political but
it was done at the behest of the office
of personal professional
responsibilities which is not a
political office and their conclusions
about his conduct apparently devastating
congressman Duffy yes although I've
criticized Jeff Sessions quite a bit
that he actually held back a little bit
and waited for the Office of
Professional Responsibility to give us a
recommendation in regard to mr. McCabe I
think he handled it correctly but Laura
no one gets fired in the swamp that we
have a former head of the FBI who's now
fired I think shows that the system
actually can work and I look at the FBI
not the the boots in the ground but at
the top of the FBI this place is rotten
and thank God Donald Trump was elected
so we can start clearing out all of
these rotten individuals who are playing
partisanship now with one of the most
powerful agencies that exist in
Washington think back to Lois Lerner I
mean Lois Lerner
at the IRS who targeted conservative and
conservatives and conservative groups
the status quo was you leave those
people in you let them retire and you
let them get their pensions under Donald
Trump draining the swamp you start
firing people who violate the ethics
within their agency or violate the law
this is a great thing yeah there's a
Frank Montoya jr. former senior FBI
official saying that this is a political
hit job on McCabe his supposed
ideological bias the fact his wife ran
for office as a Democrat the attacks on
his competence are way out of line Sarah
again no because this can't be a
political hit job if opr the Office of
Professional Responsibility got
documentation provable facts that he
violated his oath as an FBI agent and
lied and who did he lie to he lied to
the inspector general he probably lied
to other FBI agents and this could be
leading to criminal charges
so no I'm sorry I know they want to
defend him he did serve his country it's
a tragedy that we see this happen before
everyone but we really
need to know the truth and this the FBI
as well as other agencies really need to
be cleaned out what's he under
investigation before the Trump
administration was this investigation
predating Donald Trump because I keep
hearing whispers about that well there
are whispers and what part of that is
due to the fact that he was under
investigation for possible Hatch Act
violations he was referred by Senator
Grassley as well to be investigated for
not appropriately disclosing the amount
of money his wife got from the you know
unsuccessful bid for the state senator
Terry McAuliffe yeah from Terry yeah and
so there were some issues there also a
sexual discrimination lawsuit you know
there were issues there yeah that he had
to deal with but this investigation
spiraled out of the evidence that came
forth when we started to realize it
McCabe was at the center of this Comey
was at the center of this text messages
the investigation if that Michael
Horowitz is done exceptionally well my
good role yeah go ahead oh yeah let's go
let's go
Sean Sean hold that thought for one
second because we have congressman mark
Meadows from the house freedom caucus
member of the Oversight Committee
congressman meadows look we for four
months have been saying how did you have
the same people who were investigating
Hillary's private email server also
oversee the investigation into Donald
Trump's possible collusion with the
Russians we saw that with Peter struck
we then found his text messages and now
the conclusion by the Office of
Professional Responsibility about Andrew
McCabe leading to his firing tonight
your reaction to this huge breaking news
night congressman meadows well it is
unbelievable news and like my good
friends John Duffy was talking about the
fact that no one ever gets fired from
the FBI and DOJ without there being real
credible evidence so the suggestion that
this is a political hit job is just not
accurate I mean when you look at the
responsibilities of OPR you know they've
got certain guidelines that they go by
but but what it does call into question
or is this is if you have
now Peter struck and Andy McCabe both
having questionable you know actions on
their part what does it mean about the
whole investigation and what is led up
to that I can tell you there's more
information coming the inspector general
is doing a very good job but this action
tonight would not have happened if there
was not credible wrongdoing on the part
of Andrew McCabe what about the morale
of the FBI at this point we've heard for
some time that there's been a you know a
desperately low morale the credibility
FBI being questioned over the last few
years even going all the way back to
9/11 of course for the CIA and the
intelligence there but the Intel
community you know they have this
vaunted reputation they're there to
protect us so what about the FBI's
morale congressman Duffy at this point
can it begin to recover
will this be seen as a shot across the
bow the professional career agents I
think they don't they don't like this
cloud hanging over the FBI they just
want to do their job there's they're
good people there I agree they show up
they sign up to serve their country in
the FBI are the DOJ and when you have
the top of an agency or a bureau that's
rotten like this it's disheartening but
I think you give them hope when you
start to clear it out and say you know
we're gonna get back to the basics back
to an honorable organization and so I
think this is the beginning of a new and
fresh start for the FBI but I Laurel I
think is interesting though we've been
wondering how did all these leaks happen
how are all these stories getting into
the press over the last year and a half
on Donald Trump investigation and now we
see that it was coming from Andrew
McCabe and and and from from James Comey
himself the question I have is remember
when when call me went in briefed Donald
Trump on the dossier no one reported on
the dossier until someone leaked that
that the Comey was actually briefing the
President on the or the the
president-elect Donald Trump on the
dossier they lead at the CNN and all of
a sudden every news outlet career poor
news outlet could report on the dossier
the leaking that came I think from the
FBI and the DOJ was advancing their
story against Donald Trump and it wasn't
some low-level
people it appears from the information
we're now getting it was coming from the
very highest level of the FBI in the DOJ